ce soir après jimmy carter pour le prix
nobel de la paix nous nous intéressons à
imre kertész qui a reçu le nobel de
littérature son prix lui a été décerné
également aujourd'hui il est hongrois il
a 72 ans elle est publiée en france par
les éditions actes sud une oeuvre
essentiellement nourrit de ses
expériences de déportation geneviève
moll patrick voit le v6 arrivée au
sommet à l'âge de 73 ans pourtant le
hongrois imre kertész a connu une vie
écrasante et cruel
en 1944 à l'âge de 15 ans il se découvre
juifs parmi les juifs dans un camp de
concentration nazi et il ne comprend pas
la logique qui permet cette horreur
mais dans ce contexte un homme ne
comprend rien au monde qui l'entourent
il devient autistes or il ne serait pas
non plus d'être sortis vivants des camps
comment survivre en effet à cette
culpabilité d'avoir laissé mourir les
autres sinon par l'écriture
mais l'écriture est-elle le bon choix
lorsque l'on vit à partir de 1956 la
dictature hongroise et le jeu soviétique
si l'on ne peut échapper à cette
obsession ados disent la créativité
créative nvx fraude m alors on ne peut
rien faire d'autre que de suivre
obstinément ce chemin en eau
écrire elle-même dit visiblement il
publie et poursuit l'exploration de ces
négation de l'humain le nazisme
la dictature communiste mais personne ne
le lit en 1990 au moment de la
perestroïka et trouve un éditeur
allemand et son oeuvre difficile
exigeante combien le monde aujourd'hui
une vraie carte fc qu'il a fait le bon
choix
il est prix nobel de littérature